understands the missiles are already
inside Ukraine but talk to me about the
timing of the actual announcement the
House of Commons
it was an interesting announcement also
because it sounded like it was the start
of something but actually it was the end
of something we'll come on to that but
president zielinski has been very clear
that he wants a spectrum of weapons not
only to help the front line so rifles
and stuff like that but also to be able
to Target Russian forces in depth and
that's often many miles behind the front
line now the international concern was
always about the range of these weapons
it gives because it was worried that
Ukraine might try to use them to Target
Targets in Russia but the longer the war
has gone on the more the West confidence
has increased that Ukraine will stick to
its words in the US particularly
initially provided artillery out to 20
miles they need to ride high miles all
went out to 50 miles they're now looking
at capabilities to go to 100 miles they
do have some capabilities in the
offering which they've denied Ukraine
out to 200 miles but it's pretty clear
that U.S doesn't want to be seen to be
the lead here doesn't want to play to
the Russian narrative it's a fight
between Russia and America whereas the
UK has been on the Forefront of a lot of
these decisions it was the first to
Broad anti-tank weapons it was the first
to provide tanks if you remember the
challenge of twos it was the first to
provide pilot training for the Ukrainian
pilot so now it looks likely Rishi sunax
has already said earlier on this year he
was preparing for this and now this
announcement House of Commons just puts
the icing on the cake and so they're
already there they are Storm Shadow
missiles for those who aren't up to date
on their missile information what are
they what's their significance what can
they do it's one of the weapons that's
been generated for a specific Target set
which is a non-mobile Target that's very
difficult and very well protected it was
developed by the UK and France back in
the 1990s it's got a 300 kilometer range
but it's also 1300 kilograms it's a
massive Weapon It's the weight of a
small car the Jets I used to fly
harriers we couldn't carry these they
were just too heavy for us it's got a
special Warhead double part Warhead the
first bit blows a hole in its Target the
second actually goes through and
explodes the target goes through to two
to four meters of concrete so it's a
very impressive it flies at low level it
can also avoid Radars and stuff like
that and a whole host of election
Warfare capabilities that range into the
secret level so we can't talk about them
here UK procured a thousand of these
with they've used 98 they use them in a
whole range of conflicts from the Gulf
War in 2003 in Libya in 2011 and only
last year typhoons launched eight uh
across in Syria very successfully but at
two million pound a pop you know they're
quite expensive the reality here these
are 25 years old though and the reality
is the UK is looking to upgrade them but
it won't upgrade all the 902 that are
available so we actually have a whole
load of our stockpile that is available
for either disposal or use and the
ukrainians now need something so it's a
it's a marriage made in heaven in a way
okay and we keep talking about the
spring offensive drawing ever closer the
next phase of this war and how long
before we may see
these missiles used in Ukraine when I
first heard the news this morning about
the announcement I thought there's no
way that Ben Wallace will be able to say
right we're going to do it and they
suddenly appear because getting these
weapons clear to fly on aircraft is very
difficult they're very heavy and let's
not forget the flankers and the fulcrums
that the ukrainians fly are Russian
aircraft so literally getting the
aircraft to talk to the bottom okay does
it digitally Electronics but it's
completely different language so getting
those they normally takes months if not
years under the uor process urgent
operational requirements they've done
this in weeks but in parallel clearly
there's been a lot of diplomatic effort
with the US to make sure that the US and
international colleagues are comfortable
we're giving the ukrainians a 300
kilometer weapon but as you say these
weapons are in there now and the key
message here is any Russian soldier any
Russian tank that's anywhere in Ukraine
is now within range of these weapons